welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber we're bringing you the
latest on the murder trial of Alec
Murdock as the prosecution winds down
its case the South Carolina courtroom
has been front and center on the
national stage over the past several
weeks and we want to catch you up on
three big moments first up the jury has
seen video from the interrogation of
South Carolina law enforcement agents
that they conducted with Alec Murdock in
his third and final interview with them
do you think I killed Maggie I have to
go where the evidence and the fact
you think I feel Paul I have to go over
the evidence and the facts maybe and I
don't have
anything that points to anybody else at
this time
so does that mean that I am a suspect
you were still in like I told Corey
earlier you were still in this
with everything that we've talked about
with the family guns the ammunition
nobody else's DNA
I have to put my beliefs aside and go
with the facts
now one of the next big moments in the
trial came Thursday morning when judge
Clifton Newman decided that the jury can
hear about a roadside shooting that
happened a few months after the murders
you see Murdoch was shot in the side of
a road in September 2021 allegedly by
his distant cousin Curtis Eddie Smith he
was airlifted to a savannah hospital and
was interviewed by sled again originally
the judge determined that he didn't want
the jury to hear about that because it
happened months after the murders but he
reverse course late late Wednesday
because he says the defense opened the
door for that to happen when they
questioned a witness about Eddie Smith
and his connection to Murdoch
the court conducted a pre-trial a
hearing outside the presence of the jury
addressed the issue
made made it clear that the roadside
shooting was a bridge too far
then the defense decided to build a road
over that bridge
decided to just
go right there as if they could dance
through fire without
getting burned scarred or anything
the door was open
and our third big moment from Thursday
comes from a crime scene investigator
who was brought in to reconstruct the
murder scene to determine a timeline he
also clarified whether the injuries to
Paul could have been self-inflict
self-inflicted or possibly from above
number one I don't I don't know of a way
to mimic this Blood evidence on this
door Walt that pattern where that shot
traveled through Paul's shoulder into
his jaw into his brain and then took a
path up and placed the biological
material here at the top of the door if
he was shot in the head then you'd have
biological material out here on the
ground
or at least going down you know on the
sidewalk in front of you
and plus the shooter would have to be on
the roof to shoot down into him but you
wouldn't have this on the door
in your extra opinion did you see any
support or evidence in this crime scene
that could support that the injuries
suffered by Paul or in any manner a
suicide or self-inflicted
I don't see the possibility
knowing that it's not a contact shotgun
wound and I'm
I'm fairly strong and I'm bigger than
Paul was and I don't know of any way you
could hold that shotgun out
and shoot yourself in that direction at
that angle and put that biological
material on top that door like that I
don't think it's possible
let's get into it and join today by my
co-host Terry Austin a former trial
attorney and special guest trial
consultant Dina sayag doll great to have
you both here Terry I'll start with you
first judge Newman said that the
roadside shooting wasn't relevant now
he's allowing the evidence in do you
think it was strategic on his part to do
it this way definitely judge Newman is
very smart first of all he's following
the facts of this case and he knows the
law he actually reads the cases and I
think he is being strategic he is
protecting that record he let the
financial crimes in but he decided for
this roadside it wasn't relevant until
that door was open and he said the
defense opened that door and now we are
seeing evidence of that roadside we saw
you know agent Kelly talking about the
fact that all of this is coming in so I
think it's a smart move in the judges
party well Dina the jury has heard a lot
of information over the last few weeks
do you think the crime scene
investigator did a good job getting his
point across
in Steam which it should because it's
almost over and they were able to I
think clarify a few points eliminate the
suicide idea which seems kind of
ridiculous but the defense made a good
um question there by questioning them on
how long it took for them to investigate
the mother's home because the
prosecution took so much time talking
about whether or not a tarp our rain
jacket was brought in and yet you know
if the weapons were there he had months
to get rid of them and unfortunately
it's that messiness that the police that
might hurt the prosecution's case well
clearly we're going to continue to
follow this case because there's a lot
of ways to talk about
and welcome back everybody the woman
representing alleged University of Idaho
murderer Brian coburger has the
opportunity to make some extra money
while she works on his case Ann Taylor
is a public defender in Kootenai County
Idaho she's going to be representing
co-burger in later County now according
to an agreement Lata County will pay
Kootenay County 200 per hour for the
40-hour work week but if she works any
overtime Taylor herself Pockets that 200
an hour the money Kootenay takes in will
likely be used to cover cases in that
county that Taylor is not there to
handle Layton county has very few public
defenders and none with experience in
capital cases while the prosecution
hasn't indicated yet whether they're
going to request the death penalty it is
still on the table Brian coburger is
accused of stabbing four college
students to death inside their
off-campus home near the University of
Idaho Kaley Gonzalez Madison Mogan Zana
kernodle and Ethan Chapin died in
November after an intense investigation
and that lasted weeks Moscow Idaho
Police announced the arrest of co-burger
he was a doctoral student Washington
State University which is just a few
miles away from Moscow coburger faces
multiple murder charges but isn't
expected back in court again until the
summer for a preliminary hearing
so Dina this case is receiving a lot of
attention how long do you anticipate
that the trial will actually last and by
the way when can we actually see it
the trial is going to be long I would
say at least probably two or three
months because you're dealing with you
know the prosecution is going to have to
bring proof all four murders separately
there is cell phone evidence there's
going to be DNA evidence there's so many
different crime scenes that this place
where they were killed his apartment the
car maybe even his family's home this is
going to take a long time by the
prosecution's point but on the other
hand they have concerns will this jury
be sequestered and if so they're not
going to want to make this case goal
that long even if they're not
sequestered you're taking jurors out of
their lives and so that's the push and
pull that the prosecution is going to
have to deal with I would say unless you
know and we also what are his defenses
is he going to plead reason of insanity
that could add time as well we'll know
as you said a lot more in that
preliminary hearing perhaps there's even
a plea deal and no trial at all well
Terry let's go back to the money issue
for a second because it seems that
defense counsel won't make you know more
money for taking the case unless she
works overtime that likely to happen in
case this complicated exactly that's
what will happen Dina hit it on the head
there's so much to do not just at the
trial but before the trial just imagine
it took weeks before the arrest was made
so there are multiple law enforcement
people who need to be interviewed to
find out how to make the connection to
the actual arrest so I do believe Ann
Taylor is going to be investigating
she's going to be using paralegals
helping her get prepared for the trial
and you know we're going to have all of
the documents that she has to review
like Dina mentioned the cell phone
documents so there's plenty to do and
she will get overtime here unless of
course you know she just was able to do
it without that but I don't think that's
going to happen because this is one of
the biggest cases in the country right
now and they want to make sure that they
give him everything that he deserves as
far as the defense it's an interesting
development in a very fascinating and
very horrifying case Dina doll Terry
Austin thank you both so much watch
everyone thanks for joining us here on
the daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America